so getting into the third issue of our
story of Deadpool vs. Thanos we actually
pick up with a bit of Deadpool's
backstory in both our last video as well
as previous videos we had talked about
how the hatred between Deadpool and Ajax
dates back to Wade's time in the Weapon
X program under the control of a man
named dr. emre skill Bru to cover some
ground for those who haven't seen the
videos I'm referencing prior to Wade's
undertaking of the name Deadpool and
becoming God's gift to comic fans
everywhere he served as a mercenary for
hire finding his way to the webinar Jam
which had been attempting to copy
Wolverines healing factor however
because wait didn't immediately
demonstrate a healing factor after
undergoing the Weapon X process he was
assumed to failure and housed under the
care of Killebrew and tortured by Ajax
during this time Deadpool was visited by
mistress death who claimed the two could
be together if he died and so attending
to achieve this he had instigated fights
with various inmates which was against
the house rules as such Wade was
sentenced to execution by Killebrew with
Ajax overseeing the procedure by ripping
his heart out now kicking out from this
flashback we find this is actually a
dream for Wade as he's currently on
Thanos his ship sanctuary too while
Thanos complements the humic factor of
Deadpool which allowed him to recover so
fast after his encounter with Ajax
during the time that he was out that had
been providing incentive for Ajax to
provide the location of mistress death
now by incentive what I basically mean
here is if Thanos has been torturing the
hell out of Ajax now what happens next
is incredibly important with Thanos his
vast intellect where Ajax is torture
wasn't enough to force him to reveal who
his bosses Thanos was effectively able
to connect the dots anyway with mistress
des cryptic warning about the duo
needing to locate the man for the hell
Thanos has come to the belief that the
mastermind behind Ajax returning to life
was Mephisto now Mephisto is a character
that we've never really talked about
outside of the Infinity Gauntlet event
and even then the discussion was limited
to his involvement with the story at the
time where Thanos addresses this event
I'd actually like to delve a little bit
deeper here within Marvel Comics in
addition to the various alternate
realities with differing versions of
some of Marvel's most popular characters
are also different dimensions now if
you're interested in a more
comprehensive explanation about this
I have a video breaking down and
detailing how the multiverse works but
one of these dimensions within the
earth-616 cottony
is called hell and is quite literally
Marvel's manifestation of Hell from
judeo-christianity as the ruler of hell
Mephisto has incredible power and is
able to challenge all but the most
formidable beings including Galactus the
Celestials Franklin Richards and a
couple of others now the issue that
Thanos faces is that while he has
incredible power he does not have the
ability to tap into the realm of
Mephisto without aid and so a Deadpool
coming up with an idea the duo visits
Black Talon again while he's not the
most powerful of sorcerers in the Marvel
Universe the power he possesses is
enough to conjure a portal allowing them
to access the realm of hell however
instead of simply being able to open a
portal
instead Black Talon has basically spent
days conjuring the formation of a portal
through his mystical means now the
reason why Black Talon agrees to do this
is due to the fact that during his
trances where he had been communicating
with the spirits of the Dead he was
informed that the idea of a Jax escaping
hell and being returned albeit in a
comatose form would serve as a warning
for those in hell that escaping would
remove their ability to function and a
true capacity now regarding how this
correlates to life in Hell the question
is answered when black towel and
Deadpool and fan o's travel through the
portal and discover that hell is
actually in the midst of a war among its
occupants now something I'd like to
point out here is that in truth we've
never really seen an honest-to-goodness
depiction of Mephisto realm before where
this area has made appearances around
100 times in Marvel Comics these
appearances have usually been through
flashbacks or small glimpses within a
comic in this story we get a full-on
view of what hell is like for the
occupants of the universe and that
according to Black Talon those who were
in Hell can detect the living
immediately after they enter the reason
why is due to the fact that those who
are resigned to Hell know only torment
and by extension wage war against one
another however the living don't suffer
that torment and because of this the
dead are basically jealous of their
existence and seek to drive the living
down to their level the other reason why
the dead can sense Stannis and Deadpool
is because they basically killed a lot
of people which most have ended up in
hell so not only are they jealous of
their continued existence but the
occupants of Hell also really
hey Deadpool and phantoms like a lot now
surely after arriving Thanos and
Deadpool and Black Talon are greeted
with the arrival of Mephisto because
Mephisto is the demon Lord of hell and
gains his powers through evil actions of
mortal races and his collection of their
souls the fist out is by nature a very
sinister being this combined with the
fact that his last endeavor with Thanos
was during the Infinity Gauntlet event
when he tried to steal the gana for
himself has basically ensure that Thanos
will not see through Mephisto s
deception and so forcing Mephisto to cut
directly to the chase what Seeley does
here is give us the truth behind the
events as they're transpiring in Hell
what we learn is that the war as it
exists is not the same as the wars that
normally transpire in this realm because
of the nature of Mephisto is power with
no souls actually entering hell due to
their inability to die
Mephisto himself is actually losing
power as a result the Lords of the other
versions of hell including dormammu's
Dark Dimension
Hellas Asgardian Hell dimension and
others have come together for the
purpose of attempting to overthrow
Mephisto and take over his realm however
in the midst of explaining to Thanos
about how the struggle is real the group
is met with the arrival of black heart
now like Mephisto black heart is someone
we've never talked about before and he
was actually a source of speculation for
this season's agents of shield when lash
first showed up within the realm of
Marvel Comics black heart is actually
the son of Mephisto however rather than
coming into existence by way of Mephisto
mating with a mortal woman instead black
heart was quite literally created when
Mephisto took all of the deception
within a single town and used his power
to molded into black heart himself who
in turn feeds on the power of deception
to attain vast abilities attacking the
group and killing Deadpool in the
process Wade is left to experience
another message from mistress death
while black heart attacks Thanos
Mephisto and black talent now during
this conflict Thanos is able to hold his
own and the reason why is that within
the realm of Marvel beings referred to
as gods are killable and that they all
have limits to their power with the
exception of the one above all and
depending on the situation the Living
Tribunal while black heart can be
considered a god due to his incredible
abilities battles himself also has vast
powers and as a result is able to go
toe-to-toe with black heart however
during the
we find that after deadpool had finished
communing with death in the space
between life and death he had come to
knowing exactly where she's being kept
as we're told
mistress death is being held by none
other than eternity the physical
representation of the universe itself
and in turn is powered by everything
within the universe without being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end and let me know down in the comments
section what you guys thought about this
episode I didn't think it was too bad
but the final issue is actually pretty
hilarious and I will catch you guys
later peace